estoy a punto de hacer una de las cosas
que menos me gusta hacer lo cual es
invertir una matriz de 3 x 3
el principal chiste de invertir matrices
tan grandes digo porque las de 2 x 2 y
las podíamos invertir muy fácilmente
pero el principal chiste es hacer
cálculos con la mayor concentración
posible para que ninguna cuenta nos
salga mal ok el chiste es simplemente no
equivocarse a la hora de hacer las
cuentas el resto el procedimiento lo que
sabemos que tenemos que hacer es
realmente muy sencillo y bueno como
pueden darse cuenta yo suelo equivocarme
muchísimo con las cuentas siempre se me
va aún menos por ahí que echa a perder
el resultado pero esperemos que esta vez
no me pasen ninguna de esas cosas y
esperemos que con la práctica a ti
tampoco te pasen este tipo de cosas tan
seguido como me pasan a mí pero bueno
supongo que si hiciera yo este ejercicio
muchísimas veces dejaría de tener ese
tipo de errores además de ayudar a
prevenir que mi cerebro se degrade y
mejorar la probabilidad de que no
obtenga yo alzheimer o demencia senil
es algo que todos tenemos que hacer
todos tenemos que aprender a hacerlo son
muy útiles para resolver sistemas de
ecuaciones además de que seguramente en
algún examen vas a necesitar resolver
una matriz de tres por tres entonces
pues hay que practicarlo y tener mucho
cuidado de no regarla con los signos y
de sumar lo que tenemos que sumar de
forma muy precisa entonces pues hay que
sacarle el determinante una matriz de
tres por tres llamémoslo a esa matriz y
qué les parece si hacemos puro ceros
unos y dos es para que sea más sencillo
que vamos a ponerle un 10 a que un 1
y 111
listo yo digo que se ve bastante bonita
esta matriz y bueno lo primero que hago
yo cuando estoy tratando de invertir una
matriz de tres por tres de hecho
funciona con cualquier matriz de n n
donde n puede ser 5 80 33 que hay una
matriz de 5 x 5 por ejemplo es sacar lo
que yo le llamo bueno lo que todo el
mundo le llama la matriz de menores acá
y déjame lo escribo por aquí
y qué es eso de las matrices de menores
pues son matrices 7 es una matriz de 3
por 3 nuestra matriz de menores también
va a ser una matriz de 3 por 3 estoy
poniendo mucho espacio porque lo vamos a
necesitar entonces la primera entrada a
la entrada 11 de la matriz de menores
sería lo equivalente a esta entrada por
aquí lo que hacemos es ok tomamos esta
entrada y vamos a quitar esta columna de
acá y esta fila de acá de la matriz a y
ya lo que nos queda ósea a esta matriz
le vamos a sacar el determinante y lo
vamos a poner justo en esta entrada ok
sustituyendo la entrada de la cual
eliminamos toda la columna y toda la
fila así es que en la entrada 11 de la
matriz de menores tendríamos que poner
el determinante de 2 1 1 1
estos símbolos de valor absoluto lo que
denotan es que estamos sacando el
determinante
a este determinante le llamamos el menor
de esta entrada de la matriz
a ver déjame quito todo esto que puse
para que podamos ver la matriz a porque
pues la vamos a necesitar no
ok entonces en esta entrada para sacar
la menor de a en esta entrada
lo que hacemos es quitar toda la columna
que contiene a esta entrada y quitar
toda la fila que contiene a esta entrada
y sacar el determinante de la sub matriz
que nos queda aunque hay que era el
determinante de 2 1 1 1
entonces vamos con la siguiente entrada
vamos con esta entrada ya sabes
seguramente te ahorita ya me puedes
decir que determinante va aquí quitamos
toda la columna que contiene esa entrada
o sea quitamos todo esto y quitamos toda
la fila que contiene esa entrada y lo
que nos queda es esta matriz 0 1 1 1 le
sacamos el determinante y esa es la
menor de esta entrada entonces aquí
tenemos que escribir el determinante de
la matriz que nos queda de quitar esta
columna y esta fila si el determinante
de 0 1 1 1
111 y al igual que en la entrada pasada
este determinante es la menor de la
matriz a en esta entrada por eso le
llamamos matrices de menores aunque yo
creo que vamos a usar otro color para
que no se vaya a perder aquí entonces
como puedes prever en esta entrada vamos
a poner la menor de la matriz en esta
entrada aunque yo sea vamos a quitar
esta columna y esta fila lo que nos
queda es esta sub matriz le sacamos el
determinante y eso va en este lugar
ok tenemos que sacar el determinante de
0 2 1 1 ahora vamos con esta entrada
así es que quitamos esta fila y esta
columna y nos queda 0 1 1 1
entonces la menor de en esta entrada es
el determinante de 0 1 1 1
111 ahora vamos con esta entrada y
quitamos esta columna y esta fila y nos
queda el determinante de 1 111 gei
determinante de 111 111
y ahora vamos a sacar la menor de esta
entrada o si quitamos esta columna y
esta fila nos queda 10 11
el determinante de 10 11 ahora hay que
sacar la menor de esta entrada de la
matriz y vamos a quitar esta y esta nos
queda 0 1 2 1 0 1 2 1
y ahora en esta entrada aquí tenemos
esta columna y esta fila y nos queda el
determinante de 10 11 determinante de 10
y para terminar el último dejó el último
de los menores tenemos que sacar la
menor de la matriz en esta entrada aquí
tenemos esta columna y esta fila y
tenemos que sacar el determinante de 1
002 determinante de 1 002 listo esta es
nuestra matriz de menores y justo se
llama de menores porque cada una de sus
entradas es la menor de la matriz a
correspondiente a esa entrada y ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es calcular cada
uno de estos determinantes y esa es
nuestra matriz de menores
nuestra primera menor de la matriz el
determinante es 2 por 12 menos uno por
uno a uno o sea dos menos uno y eso es
un 1 que va por aquí de esta matriz el
determinante es cero por 10 menos uno
por uno menos 10 - 1 - 10 por 10 menos
dos por uno menos dos o sea menos dos y
bueno mira la verdad es que no era
necesario escribir todos estos
determinantes pudimos haberlo hecho
directamente aunque entonces si
queríamos sacar este menor lo que
podíamos hacer es ok decir bueno
queremos sacar el menor de esta entrada
entonces quitamos esta columna y esta
fila y tenemos que sacar el determinante
de lo que nos queda o sea de 0 por 10
menos uno por uno eso es menos 1
entonces aquí tenemos que escribir menos
y lo podemos escribir sin tener que
escribir todo este determinante que fue
escribir mucho pero me pareció que
quedaba más claro entonces para sacar
este valor de la matriz de menores
quitamos esta columna y esta fila y
tenemos el determinante uno por uno
uno menos uno por uno menos 11 menos 100
ok entonces no tuvimos que haber escrito
todo esto porque así es más fácil pero
bueno ya que lo escribimos pues vamos a
usarlo no entonces de este menor que es
lo que nos queda uno por uno 1 - 0 por
10 o sea 1 bien bien de esta entrada que
es lo que nos queda 0 por 10 menos uno
por 2 o sea menos 20 - 2 - todos cuidado
con esos errores uno por uno
1 - 1 por 0 1 - 0 1
y finalmente nuestra última entrada 1 x
2 - 0 x 0 0 2 - 0 esos 2 2 y listo esta
es nuestra matriz de menores y ya
estamos mucho más cerca de encontrar la
inversa de la matriz a ahora muy
importante muy importante vamos a usar
una cosa que se parece muchísimo a un
tablero de ajedrez pero donde los
cuadritos blancos son signos de más y
los cuadritos negros son signos de menos
porque o sea si tenemos una matriz de
tres por tres vamos a tener un tablero
de ajedrez de 3 x 3
donde en la primera entrada de arriba
hasta la izquierda tenemos un signo de
más después como en cualquier tableta de
ajedrez tenemos signos menos alrededor y
signos más alrededor y menos y más
esto sí es un tablero de ajedrez con más
y menos en el verde blanco y negro el
chiste es que ahora vamos a hacer una
matriz de cofactores eso eso de que es
una matriz de cofactores lo vamos a
escribir por acá matriz de cofactores y
qué es eso de la matriz de cofactores
pues es simplemente esta matriz de
menores aplicarle estos signos ya qué me
refiero con aplicarlos pues vamos a
verla ahorita y en la primera entrada
pues da la primera entrada de nuestra
matriz de menores aplicándole este signo
aunque si tenemos aquí un más aquí vamos
a poner más lo que teníamos aquí que es
un 1 sea más un norte entonces nos queda
un 1 ahora aquí tenemos un signo menos
que le vamos a aplicar a esta entrada
entonces menos menos uno pues menos por
menos dar más
así es que aquí tenemos un +1 un menos
-1 menos menos uno
ahora a este menos 2 le aplicamos el
signo más nos queda más menos 2 y eso
nos queda menos 2 a este menos uno le
aplicamos el signo menos y nos queda
menos menos uno o sea más uno vamos a
ponerle aquí el más uno luego más 0 nos
queda cero
y menos más 1 - 1 - 1 y más menos 2 eso
es menos dos y luego menos más 1 eso es
menos 1 y finalmente más +2 eso es
simplemente 2 gay esta es nuestra matriz
de cofactores nuestra matriz de menores
aplicándole nuestro tablero de ajedrez
y ahora estamos un paso más cerca de
encontrar la inversa de nuestra matriz a
porque la matriz a inversa es
simplemente uno entre el determinante de
la matriz a por la matriz adjunta de la
matriz
aunque y que exceso de la matriz adjunta
pues eso de la matriz adjunta es
simplemente en la matriz de cofactores
transpuesta aunque ya ahorita vamos a
ver qué significa eso entonces ya nada
más nos falta encontrar el determinante
de a y transponer esta matriz así es que
haber matriz adjunta de a es igual a la
matriz de cofactores transpuesta vamos a
escribirla acá
a ver para encontrar la transpuesta de
una matriz pues lo que hacemos es tomar
las filas y convertirlas en columnas y
las columnas convertirlas en filas
aunque hay dos formas de hacer eso una
es tal cual agarrar esto y circular lo y
decir ok como esta es la primera fila
ahora va a ser la primera columna iba a
estar por acá
o la otra es es pensar ok a ver esta
entrada está en la fila número uno
porque contamos aquí para cada uno y en
la columna número dos porque contamos 1
2 para acá entonces está en la segunda
columna y entonces como es la entrada
número 12 entonces lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es que sea la entrada número 21 a
ver cuál es la entrada 2.1 es aquí
tenemos tenemos que contar dos filas
hacia abajo 1 2
una columna hacia la derecha o sea aquí
que esto sea menos -1 y no va a quedar
aquí
que esta es la entrada 21 a ver pero
vamos a borrar todos esos números 1 que
la entrada 21 si se fijan todos los que
están todos los números que están en la
diagonal estos se van a quedar en su
lugar porque porque si está en la
diagonal es porque es de la forma 1,1 de
la forma 2,2 o de la forma 33 o sea el
número de la fila en la que está es
exactamente igual al número de la
columna en la que está
entonces todos estos se queden en su
lugar 102
y todos los que están fuera de la
diagonal podríamos decir que aquí
ponemos un espejo y se reflejan ok aquí
claramente vimos que este fue a dar a
este lado aquí este menos 2 va a quedar
justo en la otra esquina se va a quedar
por acá y bueno esto de que éste también
fuera un -2 fue mera coincidencia de
hecho aquí este ejemplo fue muy malo
para hacer esta transporta porque la
transporta va a ser igual a la original
lo cual pues no va a reflejar la
naturaleza de lo que es transponer una
matriz pero ni modo se entiende no
tomamos este menos uno y lo reflejamos a
lo largo de esta diagonal y nos queda
por acá
o tomamos este -1 y lo reflejamos del
otro lado de la diagonal y nos queda por
acá y este uno ya lo pusimos por acá
este uno viene por acá y este menos dos
va a dar por acá entonces esta es la
matriz de cofactores transpuesta
transpuesta y esta matriz es a la que
todo el mundo le llama la matriz adjunta
de entonces ya calculamos la adjunta de
a y ya nada más nos falta calcular el
determinante vea ok pero para eso saben
que vamos a borrar esta matriz de con
factores que ya no la matriz de
cofactores es justo lo único que no
debemos borrar porque va a ser muy útil
entonces vamos a borrar estas dos qué
mal que ya la ralla tanto pero pues de
ánimo
entonces ahora sí a sacar el
determinante de tal vez recuerdes cómo
se hace eso a ver qué es lo que hacíamos
bueno se puede hacer con cualquier fila
podemos escoger esta fila o esta fila o
esta fila
pero para hacerlo más sencillo siempre
vamos a escoger la primera fila vamos a
tomar esta fila y lo que hacemos es
tomar esta entrada y multiplicarlo por
la menor de la matriz con respecto a
esta entrada
aunque vayamos toda la primera columna y
toda la primera fila y tomamos este
determinante y lo multiplicamos por la
primera entrada o sea tenemos aquí 1 por
el determinante de 2 1 1 1 pero qué
creés esto es igual a la primera entrada
de la matriz de cofactores porque justo
así hicimos la matriz de cofactores
entonces si ya hicimos todo el trabajo
de formar la matriz de cofactores pues
vamos a usarla no así es que
en esta fila tomamos esta entrada
y lo multiplicamos por la primera
entrada de nuestra matriz de cofactores
que en este caso es un 1 y después nos
vamos a la segunda entrada
y vamos a sumar la segunda entrada cero
por la menor de la matriz a en esta
entrada
quitamos esta columna y esta fila y
sacamos el determinante de lo que nos
queda y aquí ya estaba yo haciendo uno
de esos errores que nunca hay que
cometer haciendo las cuentas sacando la
inversa de una matriz
y es que aquí aquí no va aún más va aún
menos ok por el determinante de 0 1 1 1
este tipo de errores son los que uno
tiene que tener mucho cuidado de no
hacer aquí hay que recordar nuestra
matriz de signos que no sé por qué borre
donde tenemos un mes menos más y aquí
como tenemos un más tenemos que empezar
con un menos vamos a escribirlo hasta
acá y aquí menos menos más menos menos
más ya está nuestro tablero de ajedrez
ok entonces tomamos esta y la
multiplicamos por su menor aunque que
era uno por uno y después tenemos que
restar la multiplicación de esta entrada
por la menor de la matriz a con respecto
a esta entrada o sea por este
determinante pero eso es exactamente
igual a sumarle la multiplicación de
nuestra entrada cero
el valor de nuestra matriz de cofactores
justo en ese lugar o sea aquí este que
es un 1
y si nos queda eso pues si no porque
pues de hecho así construimos este valor
ok 0 por 10 menos uno por uno menos uno
por menos uno si es exactamente el mismo
valor tiene que ser el mismo valor
porque justo justo esto de aquí justo es
el valor de nuestra matriz de ccoo
factor en este lugar aunque entonces en
lugar de hacer tantas cuentas
en lugar de hacer tantas cuentas podemos
simplemente sumarle la segunda entrada
cero por el valor de nuestra matriz de
cofactores ok por 1 entonces a ver
dígame rapidísimamente qué es lo que
tiene que estar aquí pues simplemente
esta entrada que es un 1 por la matriz
de cofactores que es un -2 y por menos 2
y entonces nos queda que nuestro
determinante es uno más
0 - 2 ok 1 - 2 eso es menos 1
entonces nosotros ya tenemos aquí todos
todos los elementos para encontrar la
matriz inversa la inversa es igual a 1 /
menos 1 pues simplemente es menos 1 no
menos uno por nuestra matriz adjunta
esta matriz que hay así es que
vamos a escribirla por acá
esta es nuestra matriz inversa entonces
tenemos nuestra matriz adjunta a que
recuerden que es la matriz de cofactores
transpuesta y esta la tenemos que
multiplicar por menos 1 entonces bueno
de hecho lo que podemos hacer es
simplemente ponerle menos 1 menos uno
más uno aquí este era aún más recuerden
entonces vamos a ponerle
qué es un menos
esto da lo mismo que le pongamos pero
deberíamos ponerle menos cero más uno
más dos más uno y menos dos
y esa es nuestra matriz inversa de hecho
yo planeaba demostrar que realmente esta
matriz si la multiplicamos por esta
matriz realmente nos daba la matriz
identidad pero como ya no tardamos
demasiado tiempo pues va a tener que ser
un ejercicio para ti chécalo yo creo
creo casi meto mis manos al fuego que
esta vez no me equivoque en las cuentas
ojalá que sea cierto y bueno ya viste
que si es complicado hacer esto de
invertir matrices de tres por tres y que
realmente hay muchísimos momentos en los
que uno se puede equivocar pero que a
final de cuentas no está tan complicado
no o sea con que no te equivoques en las
cuentas está bien sencillo y espero que
después de este vídeo esté bien claro
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo